you and i have been uh through a lot
together
i guess we could use this as an
opportunity for some
collegial therapy about the presidential
campaign
and then our time afterwards uh
but you and i bonded over the fact that
it seems like the media was
more interested in presenting some
figment of their imagination that
the actual individuals that that we were
um and certainly i felt like that was
true in your case where
you had this breakout debate performance
on one of the the first two debates and
you were one of those google people
for everyone uh everyone was really
excited about you and they saw what i'd
seen already which is that you were
speaking the truth and connecting with
with folks in a really important way
and then it was almost like like this
strange uh shark attack where it seemed
like everywhere you looked
there was some kind of negative media
treatment like it's like oh no no
like you you can't be excited about this
person uh and that that was the way it
seemed
from my perspective but certainly from
your perspective
i'm sure it was much more visceral
well it didn't just seem that way it was
that way
clearly someone said get that woman off
the stage
that was very clear and i saw it in some
of their eyes backstage after the debate
when we were in the spin room
i saw some people whose eyes said lady
you're dead you will not be coming back
but i underestimated
the viciousness the the strategy the
obvious talking points she's dangerous
she's crazy
she's she's uh anti-science she's
anti-vac
she's you think i was well whatever
and so yeah it came it was ubiquitous
wasn't it
that i had told age patients
not to take their medicine which was
particularly ridiculous given my
history with aid patients and the fact
that at that time there was no medicine
i mean the most vile and vicious things
actually
um and i thought in terms of you
it was particularly interesting because
i thought that the misogyny was very
clear
you did things andrew that i thought
were adorable like when you put
whipped cream in your volunteers mouths
and when you crowd surfed and you know
all that
if i had done those things so
yeah it was uh quite something
well certainly you can't live in america
and not
know that gender plays an enormous role
in treatment of really
anyone but political and presidential
candidates at a much higher level
and i agree with you that some of the
things that
happened on my campaign would have
seemed very very different
if if it had come from another candidate
and also you didn't have any previous
political experience
so why did they make that such a big
deal in my case but not in yours
so well they made it a big deal in my
case too
yeah not the same way you know it's not
the same way
you were no well i mean the media
treatment of the two of us
was different for sure uh and
like the the caricatures they painted
were different and and that it was
painful
for me uh watching what
people um were writing about you given
that you and i had connected so like i
knew you for months before
these this these debates occurred uh
and if you speak to someone individually
you can tell that they're thoughtful
patriotic uh sincere
and then when you see various things
being written about them you're like
well where the heck did that come from
and i agree with you like i'd
underestimated the
uh the capacity of the media to
write a story that suited their needs
rather than something that they were
actually interacting with in
in real life yeah and the lack of
journalistic ethics the using anonymous
tweets as a
source uh a lie a false narrative is
repeated and then they just repeat it
again and repeat it again
the interesting thing and the sad thing
for me was that when i actually spoke to
audiences
people knew who i was but what that
smear did was convinced
so many people that they didn't want to
come hear me
but i don't leave the experience
just with those memories i leave the
experience with
very inspiring and motivating and
encouraging and loving memories because
as you know
because you were there doing the same
thing the people that we were talking to
the voters were fantastic now there's
the voters and then there's the
political media industrial complex
you fared better by the media political
machine than i did but we had the same
experience of the voters
and it was wonderful and
that that gap between those two
uh i find tragic because
what you represented what i represented
what bernie represented in our own
different ways
was a different conversation a new
conversation one that did not adhere
to the same old same old formulations
and what i experienced is
you did too is that the people are ready
for that the problem is not with the
decency the dignity
or even the regenerative interest of the
american people
um and that's where our democracy is
broken and i hope
uh as uh the months and years unfold
that that rupture can be healed
wherever i went people loved you and i
had the same experience that you did
where
when you have conversations with actual
voters
or families just trying to to improve
their lives
it was essentially a completely
different conversation yes
than what was being had uh in the media
and that connection was
for me profound i think you had more
experience having that connection with
with people than i
because you've been
a spiritual leader for so long did you
watch
the i i watched both the dnc and the rnc
i thought you were great by the way i
thought you were wonderful um yes i
watched all of the democratic and all of
the republican
me too and uh you know like it was
it was a fascinating parallel universe
like i felt myself dropped into with uh
really to some extent both of them
honestly um but
uh but i recognized more of one than the
other uh
and the and the the rnc i joked
uh that it it felt like uh like the
movie starship troopers to me i don't
know if you remember that movie
no but i saw you tweet about it and i
looked it up
yeah i was a satire but the
authoritarianism is what the movie was
well i didn't think it was satire at all
it was the very real thing
i thought that the republican convention
was evil genius
i thought it was brilliant in its
maleficent maleficence maleficent
yeah it was malevolent in a brilliant
way um
i the way they took genuine moments
genuine human authenticity and they
wrapped it around big lies
uh i i i thought it was brilliant
in a very evil way and also the thing
that i felt was the saddest as someone
who wants
joe biden to win very badly
they prosecuted a case against joe biden
why didn't the democratic convention
prosecute a case against donald trump
if ever there was a prosecutable
criminal in the white house
here it is they didn't prosecute a case
kamala harris is a famous prosecutor
why didn't you prosecute a case and the
other thing is
the republican party even though the
vast majority of it was lies
bragged about policies we did this
most of the time it was a lie we're
going to do that most of the time it's
probably a lie the democratic convention
where was the policy so i
hope that something was learned by the
strategists
in the biden campaign
and i hope they come out swinging much
harder
uh in the weeks that we have left
what you say about the rnc
it's true that they would take real
human stories
human sentiment individuals and then
they would
wrap them in this other set of ideas or
values or
propositions uh and you would see it and
the the wild thing even for me where i'd
be like well that part of it
i appreciate and value and agree with
but they've taken it
someplace else that you know i don't
agree with or appreciate our value at
all
and that was like a repetitive theme but
you're right it was very well done
it was so they will take some story
that is so touching and so real that if
you didn't know the facts if you didn't
know the larger context you think wow
these people really care
it was like a purse thief saying look
over there look over there
so they had you look over here so they
weren't looking over there
where what was really happening and that
had to do with race it had to do with
the economy
it had to do with everything um
they're playing a very tough game
one of the things i said repeatedly on
the campaign trail
was that the only way to beat outrageous
lies is with some outrageous truth
and i hope we're going to see some more
hard-hitting
outrageous truths over the next few
weeks for the democrats now
on the campaign trail there were to be
honest
only three of us really laying down some
outregisters and that was you and me and
bernie
and tulsi to some extent so
i hope a more radical level of
truth-telling
will be adopted uh over over the next
few weeks
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode